okay good people of the internet variety
I am here to talk about the biggest
bunch of [ __ ] since the subject of
the last video that I made for the sake
of : [ __ ] on something and that is
the avatar blu-ray release and something
tells me I'm not the only one who feels
this way so I got my buddies the schmoes
here to help illustrate the point Thank
You Jeremy John John okay so the reason
that I find this release [ __ ] is the
blu-ray / DVD of Avatar that was
released on April 20th is the bare-bones
just the movie version that's all we get
no outtakes no special features no
making of does it even have subtitles
probably but nothing else they change
the game with the 3d and everything no
we play the game you know the game the
game is to release your huge movie as
quickly as possible
and just give the folks the bare-bones
movie yeah so it'll show up $30 for that
and then oh look it's Christmas time
what do you want I want avatar with I
don't know a special feature to battle
hell the full sex scene and this
wouldn't piss me off so much if this was
the end game if they just planned on
releasing the bare-bones version now and
forever and that's all we get and we
just have to deal with it forever or the
next five years then hey that's just how
it goes but that's not the case the
studio plans to release this version now
then in November released their special
edition uber every special feature known
to man on it plus 30 minutes of extra
footage then in 2011 released the
special edition 3d version and this is
all just [ __ ] to get more money out
of you and to get you to buy the same
thing three times over you want to run
out you want to buy it because you want
to watch how cool it is it's best
especially now with all the high def TVs
everybody has you have to watch how
coolest movie looks and then you're
gonna buy it again in December it's like
Lord of the Rings and Star Wars - that's
exactly what George Lucas does wait a
minute Star Wars and Avatar do they have
something in common
oh yeah the stinkiest [ __ ] studio on
earth that's run by thank you I mean
couldn't they just do what most DVDs
used to do and release the bare-bones
version and the special edition version
at the same time you know so we at least
have a choice as to what we want I'm
just saying if a studio is gonna money
grub they can at least be courteous
about it and released a special edition
of the theatrical cut now with some
special features and whatnot
then in November release your uber e^x +
alpha
turbo version with 30 minutes of new
scenes in the movie
way more special features than the
initial special edition release of the
blu-ray kind of like what Lord of the
Rings did money-grubbing yeah but at
least we get something now I just feel
like I'm in the VHS days where I have
just one option watch the movie here's
the thing if you spent like five years
making a movie and you invented 3d
technology to get it done you'd probably
have some cool stuff on the cutting room
floor then we would all like to take a
look at I think they'd come up with a
strategy then here's what you do your
Netflix avatar now okay if you want to
watch it but again you don't need to see
avatar right now you know why because
there's a huge summer movie season
coming up you can check out our preview
I suppose now very nice guys but wait
there's a bunch of huge summer action
movies and then you're gonna get into
September are you gonna get it October
that you're gonna have this there's
romantic sweeping Oscar season long and
then you can go out and get the avatar
special edition for Christmas pop it in
boom right back to square one and I just
found out that three blu-ray releases
are just not enough because Fox plans to
re-release avatar in theaters in August
with 30 minutes of extra scenes so it's
basically the same version that's gonna
be released on blu-ray in November so
after that version hits theaters and
becomes the norm and then gets released
on blu-ray in November do you think
you're ever gonna crack open that first
release bare-bones version ever again I
hope so for the sake of you getting your
money's worth but probably not so yes
this is [ __ ] do not buy the avatar
blu-ray yet if for nothing else out of
protest not that it matters because it's
already stomped blu-ray sales records
but if you really need to watch Avatar
before its special edition release in
November as the smo said Netflix or as I
said the special editions coming out in
theaters in August
that's the schmoes that's what we know
Thank You Jeremy Jones lumpy buddy yeah
check out Jeremy on one of our reviews
did you repo man but he's coming back
Jeremy's coming back and I hope he's
feeling better so if you bought the
avatar blu-ray or DVD and don't care
about special features or extra footage
in the movie and you're probably set but
if you do and you just bought the avatar
blu-ray or DVD Dan you might have just
bought the most elaborate coaster of all
time and I would like to think that
schmoes for adding their flavor to this
video love doing collaborations with you
guys we'll do more you guys Rock and
everyone can check out more of me or the
schmoes here